Colin was 14, a straight-A student, in a program for gifted kids. But he hated school. And this spring, a few weeks before the end of eighth grade, before he would leave middle school forever, he looked at his grade point average, did a little calculation, and realized something kind of amazing.
科林14岁，是个门门功课全A的优等生，还在学校的尖子生项目中。但他讨厌学校。今年春天，在八年级结束前几周，在他即将永远离开初中之前，他看了看自己的平均绩点，做了一点计算，意识到了一件相当惊人的事情。
I had a high enough GPA that I could flunk every class in eighth grade all the way through, and I would still graduate. Even if I had turned in nothing, I would have had a D average for that semester. And the D average would turn into an overall B average overall. And so, I had no reason to go. So I didn't go.
我的绩点高到就算我把八年级的每一门课都挂掉，我依然能毕业。就算我什么都不交，那个学期我也会有D的平均分。而这个D的平均分会变成总平均分B。所以，我根本没理由去学校。于是我就没去。
He didn't just quit school all at once though. For a while he went to class. But quietly, and deliberately, stopped doing his work, on principle.
他并不是一下子就退学的。有一阵子他还是去上课。但他悄悄地、刻意地停止完成作业，以此作为抗议。
There were lots of days where I just didn't do any work at all. And I would just sit through class and wait for the bell to ring, and give the appearance that I was working, or copy off people, or things like that, and so.
有很多天我根本不做任何作业。我就坐在教室里等着铃声响起，还要装出一副我在学习的样子，或者抄别人的，诸如此类，就是这样。
Wasn't it more boring, doing nothing?
什么都不做，不会更无聊吗？
No.
不会。
Did you have a book you were reading, where you could just kind of, sit in the back--
你有没有读什么书，可以就坐在后排——
No. I don't really read, so.
没有。我其实不怎么看书，所以。
Yeah. Or a magazine, or something?
是啊。或者杂志之类的？
That's something that they could point at, though. I mean, I wasn't giving them anything they could point at. So if I did something like that, then they could say, well he was reading while we were supposed to be working.
那样的话他们就能抓住把柄了。我是说，我没给他们任何可以指责我的借口。如果我做了那种事，他们就会说，我们在工作的时候他在看书。
Right.
没错。
That would be deliberately defying their instructions.
那将是公然违抗他们的指令。
Or it's just sitting there and not working.
或者只是坐在那儿什么都不干。
Right. There's nothing really they can do.
对。他们确实拿我没办法。
And when it comes to high school, will you work in high school?
那说到高中，你会努力学习吗？
Of course. Because high school, you're working towards the rest of your life. You're working toward what college you'll go to, and what college you go to decides what career you choose. But middle school? My counselor reassured me that it doesn't count for anything. That this will be all disregarded after this year is over.
当然。因为高中是在为你余下的人生打基础。你在为将来上哪所大学而努力，而你上的大学决定了你将来选择什么样的职业。但初中呢？我的辅导员向我保证过，初中成绩什么都不算。这一年结束后，这些都会作废。
He cut school completely one time. And then a second time. And both times, the school tried to call his parents, but Colin, naturally, intercepted those messages and erased them from the family answering machine. And the third day that Colin cut school, it led to a kind of uncomfortable moment for his dad.
他有一次彻底逃学了。然后又逃了第二次。两次学校都试着联系他的父母，但科林很自然地拦截了那些消息，并把它们从家里的电话答录机里删掉了。科林第三次逃学时，导致了他父亲的一个尴尬时刻。
His dad you see, is a behavior specialist for the public schools, in charge of training administrators how to keep kids doing what they're supposed to be doing. At a hundred schools, in three counties in Oregon, including the school that Colin attends.
要知道，他的父亲是公立学校的行为专家，负责培训行政人员如何让孩子们保持正轨。他负责俄勒冈州三个县的一百所学校，包括科林就读的那所。
In your job, do you deal with kids who don't show up at school?
在你的工作中，你会处理那些不去上学的孩子吗？
Yep. And I was in the school for a meeting regarding something else, and the vice principal said, oh, are you here because of the call? And I said, call? And she said, well Colin is not in school all day. And I'm like, news to me. And so I called my wife and she said, I got a call earlier--
是的。当时我在学校开一个关于其他事情的会，副校长说，哦，你是为了那个电话来的吗？我说，电话？她说，嗯，科林今天一整天都没来学校。我当时就想，这我还是第一次听说。于是我给妻子打了电话，她说，我早些时候确实接到了一个电话——
Can we just pause on that moment for a second? OK, so you're here to coach them about disciplining and controlling children. And in the middle of this, they say to you, oh by the way, you got our call about your son hasn't shown up today. What's that like for you?
我们能暂停一下讨论这个时刻吗？好吧，你是去指导他们如何管教和控制孩子。在会议中间，他们对你说，哦，顺便说一下，你接到了我们关于你儿子今天没来学校的电话。你当时是什么感觉？
It's a little, kind of, it's sort of almost like, belching in a crowd, you know. It's just a little awkward. So I left work and went home. So I went there, and there he was. Much to his surprise, he saw me walk in the door. Sort of like, what are you doing here.
那感觉有点，怎么说呢，就像在人群中打嗝一样，你知道吗。就是有点尴尬。所以我离开工作岗位回了家。我到了那儿，他就坐在那儿。让他吃惊的是，他看到我走进了门。那表情就像是，你怎么在这儿。
He came into my room and, "Where the hell have you been?" And back and forth about, what were you doing, what were you thinking, what was your logic for this? And that's when I really told him. I had enough credits to graduate, and I didn't need to pass any more classes. There's no point.
他走进我的房间，说：“你到底去哪儿了？”我们来回争论，你在做什么，你在想什么，你做这件事的逻辑是什么？就在那时我真正告诉了他。我已经有足够的学分毕业了，我不需要再通过任何课程了。没意义。
At some points in this fight, did you find yourself kind of convinced by him?
在争论的某些时刻，你有没有发现自己被他说服了？
From the beginning. I know what schools are like. I am there. I know the reality of that. It would be one thing for me to have this illusion about that. But, I mean, there's a part of me that wanted to laugh. But there's another part of me that wanted to strangle him.
从一开始就被说服了。我知道学校是什么样子的。我就在那个环境里。如果我对学校有那种幻想，那是另一回事。但是，我心里有一部分想笑。但另一部分却想掐死他。
So you're simultaneously proud of him, and completely flummoxed.
所以你既为他感到骄傲，又完全感到困惑。
Yes. Baffled. [LAUGHTER] And beside myself. And needing to get back to work. And wishing this weren't so.
是的。很困惑。（笑声）而且不知所措。还得赶回去工作。并且希望这一切都没发生。
It's kind of a stumper, what to do. On the one hand, Colin had a point. He was thinking independently, which his dad wants. Maybe the right thing to do would be to let Colin stop doing his schoolwork, and then force him to live through the consequences of that very adult decision. Maybe that would teach him something useful.
这真是个难题，不知道该怎么办。一方面，科林有道理。他是在独立思考，这正是他父亲所希望的。也许正确的做法是让他停止做学校作业，然后强迫他承担那个非常成人化的决定所带来的后果。也许那能教会他一些有用的东西。
On the other hand, Colin had a history of trying to wriggle out of his responsibilities. And so letting him wriggle out of something so big and important, it just didn't sit right. His dad tried to convince him to return to school.
另一方面，科林有逃避责任的前科。所以让他从这么大、这么重要的事情上逃避，感觉实在是不对劲。他父亲试着说服他回到学校。
That event triggered a three week period of knock down, drag out, screaming, crying, yelling. And at one point, in the middle of an argument, I said Colin, I need to-- sort of in a moment of intensity-- I sort of went time out. You know, I need to clarify something here. And that is that, I don't know that I'm right.
那件事引发了为期三周的争吵、大喊大叫、哭泣和怒吼。有一次，在争论中，我说科林，我需要——在那种紧张的时刻——我暂停了一下。你知道，我需要澄清一件事。那就是，我并不确定我是对的。
How'd that go over?
效果怎么样？
He said well that's reassuring. Sort of, well that's reassuring. So he was like, you're telling me, I got to go to school because da da da da, but you don't even know that you're right! I said, no, I don't know that I'm right. I said it's my best guess, given the information available to me.
他说，嗯，这真让人放心。差不多就是，嗯，这真让人放心。所以他的意思是，你告诉我，我必须去学校是因为叽里呱啦，但你甚至不知道自己是对的！我说，不，我不知道我是对的。我说这是根据我能掌握的信息做出的最好推测。
Colin's dad says this is par for the course. You can't raise kids without getting into situations where you don't know what to do. Because as kids develop, they fight against you, try to get their independence. And sometimes you have to let them win those fights. And sometimes you have to stop them. And at every stage in their growth, there's going to be situations where it's going to be unclear what to do, what is best.
科林的父亲说这很平常。养育孩子不可能不遇到你不知道该怎么办的情况。因为随着孩子成长，他们会反抗你，试图获得独立。有时你必须让他们赢得那些争论。有时你必须阻止他们。在他们成长的每个阶段，都会有不清楚该做什么、什么才是最好的情况。
Which brings us to the subject of today's radio program. From WBEZ Chicago, this is This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today we have two stories about adults struggling to figure out what is in the best interest of some child. And in situations where, what is best is not so clear. Act One of our program, I'd Prefer Not. In that act, as you heard, a 14 year old boy nearly gets the last word with his own father.
这就引出了今天广播节目的主题。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们有两个故事，讲述了成年人努力弄清楚什么才对孩子最有利。而且是在那种什么是最好的并不太清楚的情况下。我们节目的第一幕，“我不想”。在那一幕里，正如你听到的，一个14岁的男孩差点用言语反驳了他的父亲。
Act Two, Exodus of One. In that story, a three year old girl comes into this country from another country with illegal papers. And authorities don't know what to do with her, and make their best guess. Years later, one of the officials goes on a search to find out if they did the right thing. Stay with us.
第二幕，“一个人的出埃及记”。在那个故事里，一个三岁的女孩带着非法的证件从另一个国家来到这个国家。当局不知道该拿她怎么办，只能做出最好的推测。多年后，其中一名官员去寻找他们当初的决定是否正确。请继续收听。
Act One. I'd Prefer Not.
第一幕。我不想。
So during this three week fight between Colin and his dad, Colin did agree to go back to school until it was resolved. And one day in math class, the teacher, as you'd expect, noticed that Colin was doing absolutely nothing.
所以在科林和他父亲的三周争吵中，科林确实同意回到学校直到问题解决。有一天在数学课上，老师，如你所料，注意到科林什么都没干。
She asked me if I did my homework last night, and I said no. And she asked me why, and I said, because I don't want to. And she said, OK, well are you planning on doing it? And I said, if I feel like it. So she sent me to the office.
她问我昨晚有没有写作业，我说没有。她问我为什么，我说，因为我不想。她说，好吧，那你打算写吗？我说，如果我想写的话。于是她把我送到了办公室。
And did you say this in kind of an angry way? Or were you just as neutral--
你是用那种愤怒的方式说的吗？还是你只是很中立地——
I was no, really polite about it. I said, well, there's no point. So she sent me to the office. It wasn't like I was trying to be mean to her about it. I mean she even told my mom later that, well, he was really polite about it.
我很礼貌地说的，真的。我说，没必要写。于是她把我送到了办公室。并不是说我想对她刻薄。我是说她后来甚至告诉我妈妈，他当时非常有礼貌。
And so she sends him down to the office.
于是她把他送到了办公室。
She can't have him, I mean, it's open defiance in front of all the rest of the students. And if she says OK, the rest of the students look around, say, hmm. It worked for him.
她不能留下他，我的意思是，那是当着所有其他学生的面公开违抗。如果她说好吧，其他学生就会环顾四周，说，嗯。对他来说有效。
I was in the office, and I had been waiting in the focus room, which is basically a room with a table and a chair in it. And I was probably in there--
我在办公室里，我一直在“专注室”等着，那基本上就是一个放着桌子和椅子的房间。我大概在那儿待了——
The focus room?
专注室？
Yeah.
是的。
Meaning like, focus on what you had done?
意思是，专注在你所做过的事情上？
I guess.
我想是吧。
The focus room.
专注室。
There was one window, that had no handles on them. There's no way to get out besides the door.
那里有一个窗户，没有把手。除了门之外，没有任何出口。
Well there's no way to get out of any room besides the door.
呃，除了门，任何房间都没有出口。
Well, the window, but--
嗯，窗户，但是——
Oh, the window, I see what you're saying. [LAUGHTER]
哦，窗户，我明白你的意思了。（笑声）
They actually took the handle out of the window. And it was hot in there. And I'd probably been in there for an hour and a half, to close to two hours. And then my dad came.
他们实际上把窗户上的把手卸掉了。里面很热。我大概在那里待了一个半小时到快两个小时。然后我爸爸来了。
I walked in the room. And I said, what can I do to help? And so we left the building and walked around. And I had the, you can't throw in the towel speech.
我走进房间。我说，我能帮上什么忙吗？于是我们离开了大楼，四处走走。然后我发表了那番“你不能轻易放弃”的演讲。
Throwing in the towel, yeah, he used that a lot.
轻易放弃，是啊，他很常用这个说法。
Yeah.
是的。
It was his favorite analogy. I probably hear that about 10 times a week.
这是他最喜欢的类比。我大概一周能听到10次。
You can't throw in the towel.
你不能轻易放弃。
I said, I'm not going to let you throw in the towel.
我说，我不会让你轻易放弃的。
You can't throw in the towel. Can't throw in the towel. I mean I would hear it over and over. I could hear it coming. I could be like, oh here comes the towel. I could mouth it, I could mouth the words.
你不能轻易放弃。不能轻易放弃。我是说我会一遍又一遍地听到这句话。我预感到它要来了。我可能会想，哦，毛巾要来了。我能跟着对口型，我能把这些词说出来。
Now were you aware during this period that you were posing kind of a puzzle for your dad?
你当时意识到你正在给你父亲制造一个难题吗？
I was. And I was enjoying it.
我意识到了。而且我很享受这一点。
Say a little more about that.
多说一点关于这个。
He deals with kids who have problems like that every day. And so, he's an expert. It's like, it's trying to beat Michael Jordan on a one-on-one, you know.
他每天都要处理有这种问题的孩子。所以，他是专家。这就像，是在一对一的篮球赛中试图打败迈克尔·乔丹，你知道。
Was there like, a most satisfying moment of it? That you remember you just thought, like, yes, OK.
有没有那种最让你满足的时刻？你记得你当时就想，太棒了，好极了。
Well actually, yeah.
嗯，其实，有。
When?
什么时候？
When he told me that he didn't know if it was right. That was the moment when I thought, I really beat Michael Jordan.
当他告诉我他不知道他那样做是否正确的时候。那一刻我觉得，我真的打败了迈克尔·乔丹。
What I figured out was, that what we really needed to do is get through the end of the year. And I had this discussion with Colin. And we agreed. So what I worked out was him being able to come to Chicago from Oregon. And be with his sister for a couple of days for a weekend. And--
我最后想出的是，我们真正需要做的就是熬过这一年。我和科林讨论了这个问题。我们达成了一致。所以我安排的是让他能从俄勒冈州来芝加哥。周末和他姐姐待几天。然后——
Oh, you gave him a reward, if he would actually go to school.
哦，你奖励他，如果他真的去上学的话。
Right.
没错。
Oh. A bribe.
哦。贿赂。
Well-- yeah.
嗯——是的。
I asked your dad how it was resolved. And he said he basically just tried to bribe.
我问你爸爸事情是怎么解决的。他说他基本上就是试着贿赂。
[LAUGHTER] Did he say how he would bribe me?
（笑声）他说他怎么贿赂我的吗？
That you got to come out to Chicago.
说让你来芝加哥。
He thought-- oh, so he was trying to bribe me with the Chicago trip?
他以为——哦，所以他试图用芝加哥之旅来贿赂我？
Well, he didn't-- yes.
嗯，他没有——是的。
Is that what he said?
这是他说的吗？
That's pretty much, yeah.
差不多就是这样，是的。
Well, I guess that it-- I look at it now, and I guess yeah, he did bribe me.
好吧，我想——我现在回头看，我想是的，他确实贿赂了我。
And is that a bad thing?
那是一件坏事吗？
I think it's kind of bad when you're bribing your kids. I mean--
我觉得当你在贿赂孩子时，那有点糟糕。我是说——
See I disagree with you. I think that if you're getting people to do the right thing for the right reasons, it's always best. But if that fails, getting them to do the right thing for the wrong reasons-- that's life. Sometimes that's the way it's got to go.
你看我不同意你的观点。我认为如果你能让人们为了正确的理由去做正确的事，那是最好的。但如果失败了，让他们为了错误的理由去做正确的事——这就是生活。有时事情就只能这样发展。
So you think that sometimes you just got to do the wrong thing, to get him to go and do the right thing overall?
所以你认为有时你必须做错事，来让他最终去做正确的事？
I don't think it's the wrong thing to offer you the trip as a present.
我不认为提供这次旅行作为礼物是错的事。
A present? It's now a present?
礼物？现在变成礼物了？
Well what would you do? What should he have done?
好吧，你会怎么做？他本来应该做什么？
For me, I would have said, then don't go to school.
对我来说，我会说，那你就别去上学了。
See but, he wanted you to go to school. Like, he--
看，但他想让你去学校。就像，他——
And I think I would have, actually. If he had let me stay home from school maybe a week? And I would just, I mean-- I couldn't have done it. I don't think I could have stayed home from school for the rest of the year.
我想我也许会回去的。如果他让我待在家里哪怕一周？我可能就会，我是说——我做不到。我不认为我能一整年都不去上学。
Why?
为什么？
It's kind of like, if you ever have been homesick, you know. You think it's going to be so great. But then after the first couple days, it's like, oh, I just want to get back to school.
这有点像，如果你曾经想家过，你就知道。你以为那会很棒。但过了一两天，你会想，哦，我只想回学校。
Because you felt like probably you would have been bored, you would have wanted to see your friends, it would just feel weird.
因为你觉得你可能会觉得无聊，你想见你的朋友，那会感觉很奇怪。
Right. It would. I know the days that I stayed home it felt weird. I mean, I couldn't answer the phone. I couldn't be seen. I felt like I was hiding. I mean I was hiding. It felt-- it just didn't feel right.
没错。确实会。我知道我待在家的日子感觉很奇怪。我是说，我不能接电话。我不能露面。我觉得我在躲藏。我是说我确实在躲藏。感觉——就是感觉不对。
Wow. Did you realize this at the time, or did you only realize it in retrospect?
哇。你当时意识到这一点，还是你只有事后才意识到？
I realized it at the time. I thought that if my dad had let me stay home, I would've stayed home for probably only a week at the very most. And I would have gone back to school. It's kind of like, if you gave me that much control, then I might be less rebellious.
我当时就意识到了。我想如果我爸爸让我待在家里，我最多只会待上一周。然后我就会回学校了。这有点像，如果你给了我那么多的控制权，那我可能会少一点反叛。
Colin Dunn and his father Corey, in Oregon.
科林·邓恩和他的父亲科里，在俄勒冈州。
Act Two, Exodus of One.
第二幕，一个人的出埃及记。
There are over 5,000 children each year who get caught at the borders or at the airport, trying to come into this country without a parent or a legal guardian. No legal papers. The law is clear-cut to what to do about them, but the situation often is not so clear-cut. They're taken to residential facilities. One is in Chicago, on a neighborhood street on the north side.
每年有超过5000名儿童在边境或机场被截获，试图在没有父母或法定监护人的情况下进入这个国家。没有合法证件。关于如何处理他们，法律规定得很明确，但情况往往并不那么简单。他们被带到居住设施中。其中一个在芝加哥，在北边的一个街区街道上。
It's innocuous looking. A two story, white brick building, bounded by an iron wrought fence, called the International Children's Center. It's run by a nonprofit agency under contract with the US government, and houses up to 70 children at a time, most of them teenagers, from China, Africa, Central America, and elsewhere. The average stay is two to three months.
它看起来平淡无奇。一座两层的白色砖房，由铁栅栏围起来，叫国际儿童中心。它由一家与美国政府签约的非营利机构运营，一次最多容纳70名儿童，大多数是十几岁的青少年，来自中国、非洲、中美洲和其他地方。平均停留时间为两到三个月。
During that time, the children don't know what's going to happen to them. If they're going to be allowed to stay in the United States, or they're going to be sent back. Alex Kotlowitz has this story, about one of the memorable and difficult cases that they faced in the last few years.
在那期间，孩子们不知道会发生什么。他们是否会被允许留在美国，还是会被遣送回去。亚历克斯·科特洛维茨讲述了这个故事，关于他们过去几年面临的令人难忘和困难的案件之一。
On the afternoon of December 14, 1999, at Chicago's O'Hare airport, immigration officials pulled aside a three year old girl named Georgia Norman. She had arrived at O'Hare with a woman from Milwaukee, and customs officials discovered that Georgia's visa had been forged.
1999年12月14日下午，在芝加哥奥黑尔机场，移民官员拦下了一个名叫乔治亚·诺曼的三岁小女孩。她和一名来自密尔沃基的妇女抵达奥黑尔机场，海关官员发现乔治亚的签证是伪造的。
Little was known about the girl other than her name, and that she was from Jamaica. Given her age, she couldn't tell the officials very much. And the woman from Milwaukee was vague about her relationship with the girl. So the INS, concerned that the woman might be smuggling the girl to sell her as part of a child trafficking operation, took her into protective custody and brought her to the International Children's Center.
除了名字和她来自牙买加外，对这个女孩了解甚少。鉴于她的年龄，她无法告诉官员太多。而那个密尔沃基妇女对她与女孩的关系也含糊其辞。因此，移民局担心该妇女可能在贩卖儿童，为了将其作为儿童贩卖行动的一部分卖掉，于是将她带入保护性监管，并把她带到了国际儿童中心。
She was not an obedient child when we first made contact with her.
当我们最初与她接触时，她并不是一个听话的孩子。
This is Hugo Ruiz, the center's director. For the first few weeks, Georgia threw tantrums when she didn't get her way, biting and spitting at those who tried to comfort her. She had nightmares. In the morning she'd awake disoriented, asking for her family. She refused to eat her meals. The staff at the center had such trouble with Georgia, that Hugo had to step in.
这是该中心主任雨果·鲁伊斯。最初的几周，乔治亚在得不到想要的东西时会发脾气，咬伤和朝那些试图安慰她的人吐口水。她会做噩梦。早晨醒来时她会迷失方向，哭着找她的家人。她拒绝吃饭。中心的工作人员在乔治亚身上遇到了很大的麻烦，以至于雨果不得不介入。
I took Georgia to bed. And I was talking to her, and laying her down in bed, and she lifted up her leg and kicked down as I was holding her. And she dislocated my thumb. I actually tried to grab my thumb and put it back into place, and I did, but Georgia got scared. Because she saw that she had hurt me. And she started crying. And I hugged her. And we sang some songs, and I read her a couple of stories. And she fell asleep. And I went and got an ice bag. So that was my real introduction to Georgia early on in the program.
我带乔治亚上床睡觉。我正和她说话，把她安置在床上，我抱着她时她抬起腿用力往下蹬。我的拇指脱臼了。我其实试图抓住我的拇指把它放回原位，我做到了，但乔治亚吓坏了。因为她看到她伤害了我。她开始哭。我抱住她。我们唱了一些歌，我给她读了几个故事。她睡着了。我去拿了一个冰袋。那是我在该项目中与乔治亚的真正初步接触。
Hugo, who is 54, is even keeled and patient. An immigrant himself, from Peru, on some level he identified with the confusion and uncertainty the children at the center felt. Also he had raised two daughters of his own. He continued to read to Georgia at night, and let her tag along with him to meetings downtown.
雨果今年54岁，沉着且有耐心。他本人也是来自秘鲁的移民，在某种程度上，他对孩子们在中心感受到的困惑和不确定性感同身受。另外，他也养育了自己的两个女儿。他继续在晚上给乔治亚读故事，并让她跟着他去市中心开会。
Soon, the crying and the fits stopped. Georgia began to feel at home. She had the run of the place. She was a beautiful child, with a smile Hugo said, that could put anyone under her power. And because she was so much younger than most of the children at the center, she was doted on. Especially by some of the older girls, many of whom had left younger siblings behind.
很快，哭声和发脾气停止了。乔治亚开始感到自在。她可以在那个地方到处跑。她是个漂亮的孩子，雨果说，她的笑容可以让人臣服。而且因为她比中心里大多数孩子都小得多，她被宠坏了。特别是被一些大女孩宠着，她们中许多人把更小的兄弟姐妹留在了家乡。
I miss my family, and I miss my little brothers. And I wanted to be close to her. Because it was a comfort for me, as well as for her. And we were very close. We'd take a lot of pictures together.
我想念我的家人，我想念我的小兄弟们。我想和她亲近。因为这对我来说是一种安慰，对她也是。我们关系非常亲密。我们一起拍了很多照片。
Sagal [? Abdi, ?] who was 17 at the time, was from Somalia. Like some of the other kids here, she was running from horrific memories. In her case, the brutality of her country's civil wars, which had claimed the life of her father.
萨加尔（当时17岁）来自索马里。和其他在这里的孩子一样，她也在逃离恐怖的记忆。在她的例子中，是她国家内战的残酷，那场战争夺走了她父亲的生命。
Many other kids, especially the Chinese, are sent here by their parents, often with the aid of smugglers, in the hope that they'll find work and be able to send money home. Though the kids don't know the particulars of each other's stories, they feel connected by their common experiences. Sagal became Georgia's roommate, and they became like sisters.
许多其他孩子，特别是中国人，是被父母送来这里的，通常是在走私者的帮助下，希望他们能找到工作并能往家寄钱。虽然孩子们不了解彼此故事的细节，但他们因为共同的经历而感到联系在一起。萨加尔成了乔治亚的室友，她们就像姐妹一样。
One day, Sagal learned that her effort to gain political asylum had run into some problems.
有一天，萨加尔得知她寻求政治庇护的努力遇到了一些问题。
So I was very upset. And I was sitting in my room, and she came in. And she started dancing. And she stole one of my make-up and put it on. And she put all over her face, and she was, just so cute. And I just look at her, and I started laughing. And I thought about it, and I say, this little kid, she's away from her family, she's having a good time. And just, you know, playing around. Me, I'm older than her. I shouldn't sit and cry. So we just went to the hallway and joined the other kids.
所以我非常难过。我正坐在我的房间里，她进来了。她开始跳舞。她偷了我的一个化妆品并涂在脸上。她涂了满脸，她真是太可爱了。我看着她，开始笑。我想了想，我说，这个小孩子，她远离家人，她玩得很开心。就是，你知道，玩耍。我，我比她大。我不应该坐在这里哭。所以我们就走到走廊，加入了其他孩子。
Georgia seemed to know that since she was so much younger than everyone else, she could usually get her way. Either through petty stubbornness, or through charm. I was visiting the center around that time, and I remember how the staff would break program rules for her. They snuck her extra candy. They brought her Barbie dolls, which she coveted. They hired a clown for her birthday. The older girls like Sagal used their allowances to buy her presents. And they would take turns braiding her hair. They taught her phrases in Spanish and Chinese.
乔治亚似乎知道，因为她比其他所有人都小，她通常可以通过小小的固执或魅力达到目的。那时我正在参观该中心，我记得工作人员是如何为她打破项目规则的。他们偷偷给她额外的糖果。他们给她买芭比娃娃，那是她梦寐以求的。他们为她的生日雇了一个小丑。像萨加尔这样的大女孩用她们的零花钱给她买礼物。她们轮流给乔治亚编辫子。她们教她西班牙语和中文的短语。
When the children posed for photographs, Georgia, like a little Zelig, would dance her way into these pictures. At the center she learned to ride a bike. She rode her first elevator. She learned to swim at the nearby YMCA. Meanwhile, Hugo tried to figure out her future. Which first meant figuring out her past. In the afternoons, Hugo invited Georgia to come visit him at his first floor office.
当孩子们摆姿势拍照时，乔治亚就像一个小泽利格，跳进这些照片里。在中心，她学会了骑自行车。她第一次乘坐电梯。她在附近的基督教青年会学会了游泳。与此同时，雨果试图弄清她的未来。这意味着首先要弄清她的过去。下午，雨果邀请乔治亚去他一楼的办公室访问。
And I remember sitting in my desk, and she was not quite awake yet after her nap. And she'd come in, and kind of poke her head in the door. And she just would show me her smile, and then go back outside. And I said, come on in Georgia. I would show her pictures of Jamaica. And she'd say, oh, that looks like where I used to live.
我记得我坐在办公桌前，她睡完午觉还没完全醒。她会进来，把头探进门。她只是对我展现她的笑容，然后又跑出去。我说，进来吧乔治亚。我会给她看牙买加的照片。她会说，哦，那看起来像我以前住的地方。
Even after three months at the center, no one knew much about Georgia. Where she was from in Jamaica, who her parents were, how she ended up in this country with this woman from Milwaukee. She was a three year old girl without a history. No one knew what to do with her. Three months turned into four, and eventually into six.
即使在中心待了三个月，也没人对乔治亚了解多少。她在牙买加哪里，她的父母是谁，她是如何和那个密尔沃基妇女来到这个国家的。她是一个没有历史的三岁女孩。没人知道该怎么处理她。三个月变成了四个月，最终变成了六个月。
Through all of this, the only absolute that Hugo knew, was that if Georgia stayed at the center, she'd be OK. But he knew she couldn't remain there indefinitely.
经历了这一切，雨果唯一知道的绝对真理是，如果乔治亚留在中心，她会没事的。但他知道她不能无限期地待在那里。
There were many takers in the program that wanted to take care of Georgia for the rest of her life.
项目里有很多人想在余生中照顾乔治亚。
Including yourself?
包括你自己吗？
I, unfortunately, I was probably the first one in line. I think I had been a father to her fairly easily.
我不幸的是，我可能是在排队的人里的第一个。我想我相当容易地成为了她的父亲。
Why has the US government kept this three year old in detention for six months? Eye on America investigates.
美国政府为什么要将这个三岁的孩子关押六个月？美国之眼正在调查。
In the wake of Elian Gonzales, Georgia's story made national news. And the outrage was that a three year old girl had been in custody for so long. TV crews parked outside the center. Local congressmen, along with Jesse Jackson, demanded a meeting with Georgia to make sure she was OK. Which of course she was. They wanted something done for this three year old girl. But there really weren't any clear options.
在埃连·冈萨雷斯事件之后，乔治亚的故事成为了全国新闻。令人愤慨的是，一个三岁的小女孩被拘留了这么久。电视摄制组停在中心外面。当地的国会议员和杰西·杰克逊要求与乔治亚见面，以确保她很好。当然她很好。他们想要为这个三岁的小女孩做点什么。但实际上并没有任何明确的选择。
Then a reporter from Milwaukee located Georgia's mother near Runaway Bay, a resort town on Jamaica's north coast. It appeared that Georgia's mother had willingly given Georgia to the Milwaukee woman, in the hope that she might have a better life in America. Georgia's mother also made it clear to authorities that she wanted Georgia back home. So a decision was made to reunite Georgia with her mother.
后来，一名来自密尔沃基的记者在牙买加北海岸的度假小镇鲁纳韦湾附近找到了乔治亚的母亲。似乎乔治亚的母亲自愿将乔治亚交给了那个密尔沃基妇女，希望她在美国能有更好的生活。乔治亚的母亲也明确向当局表示，她想把乔治亚接回国内。因此，做出了让乔治亚与她母亲团聚的决定。
And while that seemed like the obvious choice, it worried those who had taken care of her. What does it mean to send a child back to a parent who was willing to give her away? This question weighed heavily on Hugo.
虽然那看起来是显而易见的选择，但它让那些照顾她的人感到担忧。把一个孩子送回一个愿意放弃她的父母身边意味着什么？这个问题沉重地压在雨果心头。
When it came time to go back to Jamaica, I was the one that went back with her. And that was a tough trip. It was a very difficult trip. Every child deserves to be with their parent. In the case of Georgia, given the background of what happened, my fear would be that Georgia would be put through another episode, much like first one.
当到了回牙买加的时候，是我陪她回去的。那是一次艰难的旅行。那是一次非常困难的旅行。每个孩子都应该和他们的父母在一起。在乔治亚的情况下，考虑到所发生的事情的背景，我的恐惧是乔治亚会经历另一次类似第一次的事件。
Georgia left the center in June of 2000, just two weeks after she'd turned four. Hugo woke her early for a 6:00 AM flight. She wore her favorite outfit, a blouse with umbrellas, blue jeans, and tennis shoes with blinking lights. Hugo tried to prepare Georgia for the trip, letting her know that he was taking her to her mother.
乔治亚于2000年6月离开中心，就在她四岁生日后两周。雨果早早叫醒她去搭乘早上6点的航班。她穿着她最喜欢的衣服，一件带有雨伞图案的衬衫，蓝色牛仔裤，还有带有闪烁灯光的网球鞋。雨果试图让乔治亚为这次旅行做好准备，让她知道他正带她去找她的母亲。
But it soon became apparent that Georgia thought this was simply a visit. And that she'd return to Chicago with Hugo. When they arrived at the airport in Kingston, they were greeted by a representative from the Jamaican government.
但很快很明显，乔治亚认为这只是一个访问。并且她会和雨果回到芝加哥。当他们抵达金斯敦机场时，他们受到了牙买加政府代表的迎接。
I introduced her to the gentleman that came in from the Jamaican Child and Welfare Services, and said, this is the guy that's going to take you back to your mom. And then she asked me the real tough question, that I can still remember her little face, and she had all her favorite toys. And she went back with lots of bags and luggage. And she was holding her favorite doll, and she said, "You're coming with me?" And I had to tell her that I wasn't. Tough. Tough to see a child that trusts you and cares about you. You sort of feel like you're in them now.
我把她介绍给从牙买加儿童福利局来的那位绅士，说，这就是带你回去找妈妈的人。然后她问了我那个真正艰难的问题，我依然能想起她的小脸，她带着所有她最喜欢的玩具。她带着很多包和行李回去了。她抱着她最喜欢的娃娃，她说，“你和我一起去吗？”我不得不告诉她我不会去。艰难。看到一个信任你、关心你的孩子真的很难。你现在就像是在他们心里一样。
(PHONE BEEPS, RINGING)
（电话响声）
This past May, Hugo began to look for Georgia. She would be nearly eight years old.
去年五月，雨果开始寻找乔治亚。她快八岁了。
I'm looking for Georgia Norman. Do you know a young girl by the name of Georgia Norman? Well, I'm calling from the United States. I'm trying to find a friend of mine that I met a long time ago. And I'm just trying to find out where she's at.
我在寻找乔治亚·诺曼。你认识一个叫乔治亚·诺曼的小女孩吗？嗯，我是从美国打来的。我在寻找很久以前认识的一个朋友。我只是想弄清楚她在哪里。
In those intervening four years, Hugo hadn't stopped worrying about Georgia. He wondered what kind of life she had in Jamaica, if in fact she was still there. Maybe her mother had given her away again. In the main hallway of the center, he had hung a photo of Georgia on roller skates, taken just before she left the center, on her birthday. And he held on to the two American Airline ticket stubs that he used to fly Georgia back home. They remained in his wallet for four years.
在那中间的四年里，雨果一直没有停止担心乔治亚。他想知道她在牙买加过着什么样的生活，如果她确实还在那里的话。也许她的母亲又把她送人了。在中心的主走廊里，他挂了一张乔治亚踩着旱冰鞋的照片，是在她离开中心前不久，在她生日那天拍的。他一直保留着他用来送乔治亚回家的两张美国航空公司的票根。它们在他钱包里放了四年。
Well I want to find Georgia. I want to know what happened. I want to find out what is that has gone on in her life. One of the things that I told Georgia when we parted in Kingston was that I would see her soon. And it's been a while, and I want to be able to keep my word.
嗯，我想找到乔治亚。我想知道发生了什么。我想找出她生活中到底发生了什么。我和乔治亚在金斯敦告别时对她说的其中一件事就是我会很快见到她。已经过去一段时间了，我想能够信守诺言。
Over the past few years, Hugo had talked to me about going down to Jamaica to find Georgia. He had never done anything like this with any other children from the center. This past spring, I suggested we finally make the trip.
在过去几年里，雨果曾和我谈过要去牙买加寻找乔治亚。他从来没对中心的任何其他孩子做过这样的事。去年春天，我建议我们最终成行。
Truth was, we weren't even certain we'd be able to find her. We pulled an old phone number from her lawyer's documents. We tried calling Jamaicans with the same last name. But nothing. Then shortly before we were going to depart, I found Sheila Ramos, the Milwaukee woman who had brought Georgia into this country with a forged visa.
事实是，我们甚至不确定能否找到她。我们从她律师的文件中找出了一个旧电话号码。我们试着给姓氏相同的牙买加人打电话。但一无所获。就在我们准备出发前不久，我找到了希拉·拉莫斯，那个带着伪造签证把乔治亚带进这个国家的密尔沃基妇女。
Remember, officials initially believed that she might be trafficking in children, planning to sell Georgia. That turned out not to be the case. But given those early suspicions, I was surprised that she so readily agreed to talk to me. I would have thought she'd want to put the whole episode behind her. I drove to her home in Milwaukee, not sure what to expect.
记得吗，官员最初认为她可能在贩卖儿童，计划卖掉乔治亚。事实证明并非如此。但考虑到那些早期的怀疑，我很惊讶她竟然如此爽快地答应和我谈。我本以为她会想把整件事抛诸脑后。我开车去了她在密尔沃基的家，不确定会遇到什么。
I stop at custom, and they want to see her birth certificate. And they say, who is she? That's when I say, that's the little girl that's coming to live with me. And then that's when they say, hold up. I didn't think I did nothing wrong.
我在海关停下，他们要看她的出生证明。他们问，她是谁？那时我说，这是要来和我一起生活的小女孩。然后他们就说，等等。我不认为我做错了什么。
When Sheila Ramos tells the story of her decision to take Georgia back to the US with her, it seems surprisingly innocent. And at the same time, strangely spur of the moment. Sheila's 50 and married, works with inner city youth, and has two grown children of her own. Once a year Sheila would bring a group of Milwaukee teenagers to Jamaica, and on one visit, she met Georgia and her mother, Margaret Francis.
当希拉·拉莫斯讲述她决定带乔治亚回美国的故事时，它看起来出奇的无辜。与此同时，却又有一种奇怪的冲动。希拉50岁，已婚，与内城的年轻人一起工作，自己有两个成年子女。希拉每年会带一群密尔沃基的青少年去牙买加，在一次访问中，她遇到了乔治亚和她的母亲，玛格丽特·弗朗西斯。
Margaret would bring Georgia by the hotel so she could swim in its pool. Margaret and Sheila became friendly and stayed in touch. When Sheila returned the next year, the idea of her taking Georgia back to the US came up.
玛格丽特会带乔治亚去酒店，这样她可以在游泳池游泳。玛格丽特和希拉成为了朋友并保持联系。当希拉第二年回去时，她带乔治亚回美国的想法就提出来了。
And she came over, she said, it would be real nice if she can have a nice family to go home to. And I say well, I mean she can easily come and visit if she like. And then, she said, Sheila, that'd be real good, you know. She said you can be the godmother, or I could be her legal guardian, or something like that. And when I came back over to Jamaica, like I said two years later, she said well we're going to go to court.
她过来时说，如果她能有一个好家庭可以回家，那会很好。我说，嗯，我是说如果她愿意，她可以很容易地过来访问。然后，她说，希拉，那会很好，你知道。她说你可以成为教母，或者我可以成为她的法定监护人，诸如此类。当我两年后回到牙买加时，她说，好吧，我们要去法院。
It all seems almost, casual's not the right word, but kind of matter of fact. I mean that you don't say to her, well why would you want to give her up. It's, you--
这看起来几乎是，随意不是正确的词，但有点像理所当然。我是说你没有对她说，嗯，你为什么要放弃她。是，你——
And it could be because it's like, because I see the poverty there. So, to me, when she said because she would have a better life with you. I didn't ask questions. I said, well, yeah she will have a better life with me. Because you can see the child. You know, she was not dirty, but don't have nice clothes. I just looked at her and said OK.
那可能是因为，因为我看到了那里的贫困。所以，对我来说，当她说因为她跟着你会有一个更好的生活时。我没有问问题。我说，嗯，是的，她跟着我会有一个更好的生活。因为你可以看到那个孩子。你知道，她并不脏，但没有像样的衣服。我只是看着她说好吧。
And that was that. It didn't even occur to Sheila that she'd need anything more than legal guardianship to bring Georgia into the US. Her husband Carlos though, had reservations. And when he met Margaret, he wasn't reassured.
事情就是这样。希拉甚至没想到带乔治亚来美国除了法定监护权还需要什么别的。不过她的丈夫卡洛斯有保留意见。当他见到玛格丽特时，他并没有感到宽心。
There wasn't no curiosity coming out of her. And I said, ask me something. You know, no curiosity. No, how do you guys live, how are you going to do this. No questions was come out of her there. That puzzled me and worried me a little bit. I said, come on, man. Act like a, act like you're sad, you know. You're giving up your child, you know. But I didn't sense that, not once. Never once did she change her mind.
她没有任何好奇心。我说，问我点什么吧。你知道，没有好奇心。不问你们怎么生活，你们打算怎么做。在那儿没有任何问题出来。这让我困惑并有点担心。我说，拜托，伙计。表现得像，表现得像你很难过，你知道。你要放弃你的孩子，你知道。但我感觉不到，一次也没有。她从来没有改变过主意。
In the end Carlos gave in, because Sheila wanted it so much.
最后卡洛斯妥协了，因为希拉太想要了。
So it would be a real thrill for me, because I have two boys. And I always wanted a daughter. I would've probably spoiled her to death. She'd probably be in probably everything-- karate, ballet, model. She'd probably be in everything.
所以这对我来说会是一个真正的刺激，因为我有两个男孩。我一直想要一个女儿。我可能会把她宠坏。她可能会参加一切——空手道、芭蕾、模特。她可能会参加一切。
After spending an afternoon with Sheila, and meeting the people around her, I was convinced that her intentions were good. She runs a small youth center, and not long ago took in a 17 year old neighborhood girl who'd been abandoned by her family. The girl calls Sheila mom.
在与希拉度过一个下午，并见了她周围的人之后，我确信她的动机是好的。她经营着一家小型青年中心，不久前收留了一个被家人遗弃的17岁社区女孩。那个女孩管希拉叫妈妈。
But here's the last thing I expected to hear. Four years after trying to bring Georgia into this country, she's now trying again. She's attempting to formally adopt her. And though her first effort was denied, she is now appealing the decision. She had stayed in close touch with Margaret. There had been regular visits, and they speak every week. And so Sheila was also able to solve the mystery of how to find Georgia. She gave me Margaret's phone number, and Hugo called to arrange a visit.
但这是我最没预料到的事。在试图带乔治亚来这个国家四年后，她现在又在尝试了。她正试图正式收养她。虽然她第一次尝试被拒绝了，但她现在正在上诉。她与玛格丽特一直保持密切联系。他们有定期的访问，而且每周都会通话。因此，希拉也能解决如何找到乔治亚的谜题。她给了我玛格丽特的电话号码，雨果打电话安排了一次访问。
As we headed down to Jamaica, we worried about what kind of situation we'd find Georgia in. Whether she was still being cared for, what could be going on that her mother was still trying so hard to give her away. In a sense, things had come full circle. Four years ago, Georgia must have felt abandoned. First by her mother, then by Sheila, and finally by Hugo. And now four years later, Georgia was back with her mother, and faced being sent away yet again. It's exactly what Hugo had feared.
当我们前往牙买加时，我们担心会发现乔治亚处于什么样的境地。是否还有人在照顾她，如果她的母亲还在如此努力地把她送走，那会发生什么。在某种意义上，事情又回到了原点。四年前，乔治亚一定感到被抛弃了。先是她的母亲，然后是希拉，最后是雨果。现在四年后，乔治亚回到了她母亲身边，却又面临着再次被送走的危险。这正是雨果所担心的。
Coming up, Alex and Hugo in Jamaica. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，亚历克斯和雨果在牙买加。稍后，节目将继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Alex Kotlowitz's story continues, tracking down a little girl after four years.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。亚历克斯·科特洛维茨的故事继续，在四年后寻找一个小女孩。
We arrived in Runaway Bay, Jamaica, on Memorial Day weekend. Margaret and Georgia had agreed to meet us at the hotel that first evening. And so we waited for them near the front door, watching a game of netball on the lobby's television. They soon arrived. They were holding hands. Georgia was four years older, nearly eight now, but she looked unmistakably like the young girl I'd met in Chicago. She wore her hair in braids, two to the side like pigtails, and a double braid down her back. Hugo approached Georgia.
我们在阵亡将士纪念日周末抵达牙买加鲁纳韦湾。玛格丽特和乔治亚同意那天晚上在酒店见我们。所以我们在前门附近等她们，看着大厅电视上的一场无挡板篮球赛。她们很快就到了。她们牵着手。乔治亚长大了四岁，现在快八岁了，但她看起来确实就是我在芝加哥见到的那个小女孩。她扎着辫子，侧面两个像猪尾巴，背后垂着一根双辫子。雨果走近乔治亚。
How are you? How are you?
你好吗？你好吗？
She didn't recognize him, and hid behind her mother, clutching one of her legs.
她没有认出他，躲在她母亲身后，紧紧抓住她的一条腿。
You remember me? Do you? I know I lost a little bit of hair.
你记得我吗？记得吗？我知道我头发少了一点。
Both Georgia and her mother had dressed up for the occasion. Margaret, a sturdily built woman with a shortly cropped afro, wore a white linen shorts suit. Georgia wore a neatly ironed white button down blouse, and a short blue denim skirt. We went and sat by the pool and Georgia, understandably wary of the microphone, kept her distance. Hugo sat in a chair, and Georgia stood a few feet away.
乔治亚和她的母亲都为了这次会面精心打扮了一番。玛格丽特，一个身材结实的女性，留着短卷发，穿着白亚麻短裤套装。乔治亚穿着一件熨烫整齐的白色纽扣衬衫，和一条短牛仔裙。我们去游泳池边坐下，乔治亚，因为对麦克风保持警惕，保持着距离。雨果坐在椅子上，乔治亚站在几英尺远的地方。
So, how are you honey? You look so cute. You've grown quite a bit. You were only this size when I brought you. Do you remember when I brought you here? Do you?
那么，你好吗亲爱的？你看起来真可爱。你长高了不少。我带你来的时候你只有这么大。你记得我带你来这儿吗？记得吗？
Yes.
记得。
It's kind of like I thought. She would probably be shy and not remember, and that it would take a while to warm up. And, but, I think after a little bit of talking with her, she started to make the connection.
这跟我预想的差不多。她可能会害羞，不记得，需要一段时间才能热络起来。但是，我认为在和她交谈了一会儿后，她开始建立联系了。
We had brought along photographs of two of the teenagers who had been particularly close to Georgia in Chicago.
我们带上了两个在芝加哥与乔治亚特别亲近的青少年的照片。
Who's this?
这是谁？
Um, [INAUDIBLE].
嗯，[听不清]。
[? Bi-wi ?], this is [? Bi-wi. ?]
比威，这是比威。
One was of [? Bi-wi ?] Lin, a girl from China. And the other was a photograph taken at the center of Sagal and Georgia.
一个是来自中国的女孩比威·林的照片。另一张是在中心拍的萨加尔和乔治亚的照片。
Uh-oh, who's that?
哦，那是谁？
Me.
我。
And Sagal. Remember Sagal?
还有萨加尔。记得萨加尔吗？
Yeah.
记得。
In the photos, Sagal is kneeling, her cheek pressed up against Georgia's. Both are smiling, their arms slung around each other.
在照片里，萨加尔跪着，脸颊紧贴着乔治亚。两人都在笑，胳膊揽着对方。
And see this one, she hasn't seen this one. That's Sagal. She's from Somalia.
看这张，她还没见过这张。那是萨加尔。她来自索马里。
OK.
好的。
She used to really take care of her a lot.
她过去经常很照顾她。
Margaret smiled timidly. While she's reserved, almost shy, it was clear she appreciated hearing of Georgia's time in Chicago. Though she never asked Hugo any questions about her life there. I remembered Sheila's husband, Carlos, telling me how incurious she was. Margaret told Hugo about a visit she and Georgia took to Bob Marley's grave site. Georgia walked over from the pool at that point.
玛格丽特羞涩地笑了。虽然她很矜持，几乎害羞，但很明显她很欣赏听到乔治亚在芝加哥的那段时光。虽然她从未问过雨果任何关于她在那里生活的事。我记得希拉的丈夫卡洛斯告诉我她是如何缺乏好奇心的。玛格丽特告诉雨果她和乔治亚去鲍勃·马利的墓地参观的事。这时乔治亚从游泳池边走了过来。
I know what you're talking about. About Bob Marley. I know a lot about him. I know his [? story ?], his temper, his house. And I know when he was born and I know when he died.
我知道你在说什么。关于鲍勃·马利。我知道很多关于他的事。我知道他的[故事]，他的脾气，他的房子。我知道他什么时候出生，我知道他什么时候死。
When did he die?
他什么时候死的？
1981.
1981年。
Oh, when was he born?
哦，他什么时候出生的？
1945.
1945年。
Ah ha.
啊哈。
Georgia was warming up to Hugo. They traded facts about Bob Marley for a while. And then her attention drifted toward the pool. She waded in, and Hugo encouraged her to go deeper. She looked back at her mom, like any good kid would, for permission.
乔治亚对雨果开始热络起来。他们交流了一会儿关于鲍勃·马利的事实。然后她的注意力飘向了游泳池。她涉水进去，雨果鼓励她去更深的地方。她回头看她的妈妈，就像任何好孩子一样，请求许可。
You've done a real good job with her. She just seems like a real sweet girl, and all that she has done, is she's grown up.
你把她照顾得真好。她看起来就是个真正甜美的女孩，而且她所做的一切，就是长大了。
At the outdoor restaurant Margaret chose for dinner, a neighborhood hangout, music blared through refrigerator-sized speakers stacked one on top of the other. It was difficult to have a conversation. It was uncomfortable sitting around this picnic table, barely able to exchange a word.
在玛格丽特选择的露天餐馆吃晚餐时，那是一个邻里聚集地，音乐通过堆在一起的冰箱大小的扬声器轰鸣。很难进行谈话。坐在野餐桌旁，几乎说不出一句话，让人感到不舒服。
But it was easy to see that Margaret adored Georgia, and that Georgia adored her mom. They shared a plate of chicken. And at one point, Georgia snuggled up against her mother, and together they sang along with the music. Margaret and Hugo tried over the music to talk about the adoption. But Georgia soon ran out of food.
但很容易看出玛格丽特宠爱乔治亚，乔治亚也宠爱她的妈妈。她们分享了一盘鸡肉。有一次，乔治亚依偎在她的母亲身边，她们一起跟着音乐唱歌。玛格丽特和雨果试图在音乐中谈论收养的事。但乔治亚很快吃完了东西。
You want more jerk chicken? You do? Come on, let's go get some. Come on Georgia, help me.
你想再吃点牙买加烤鸡吗？真的？来吧，我们去拿点。来吧乔治亚，帮我一下。
They strolled to the counter.
她们走向柜台。
I asked Georgia, I said, come on, give me your hand. I haven't held your hand for such a long time. And she says, but they're so greasy. And I said it doesn't matter, here, come on, give me your hand. So she gave me her hand and we went up and walked up the steps and put the order in. And I asked her, I said, so Georgia, what do you want to do? She said, well, I want to go to Chicago.
我问乔治亚，我说，来吧，给我你的手。我已经好久没牵你的手了。她说，但它们太油了。我说没关系，来，给我你的手。所以她把手给我，我们走上去把订单交了。我问她，我说，那么乔治亚，你想做什么？她说，嗯，我想去芝加哥。
That sort of surprised me. It surprised me that she would say that. I said why, she says, because I like it there. And I just wonder what it is that she liked about Chicago. Or I wonder if, as some of the other children sometimes are, if she was coached to say that.
这让我感到有点惊讶。我很惊讶她会那样说。我说为什么，她说，因为我喜欢那里。我只是想知道她喜欢芝加哥什么。或者我想知道，正如其他一些孩子有时会被指点那样，她是否被授意那样说。
Georgia's answer unnerved Hugo. It wasn't what he had expected. Especially after only a couple of hours together. Hugo and I assumed that Georgia was mimicking what her mother clearly wanted for her. As close as she and Georgia seemed, she was still planning to send her to live with Sheila in America. Back at the hotel, Hugo and I talked about the evening.
乔治亚的回答让雨果感到不安。这不是他所预料的。尤其是在两人只在一起待了几个小时之后。雨果和我认为乔治亚是在模仿她母亲显然为她所希望的事情。尽管她和乔治亚看起来关系很亲近，但她仍然计划把她送去和美国的希拉住。回到酒店，雨果和我谈论了那个晚上。
I'm happy that she is the way she is. She's clearly attached to her mom. She seems like a very normal kid.
我很高兴她现在的状态。她显然很依恋她的妈妈。她看起来像个非常正常的孩子。
It must be somewhat of a relief. Because I know you were anxious, and I know I was anxious, and I didn't have anywhere near as much at stake as you did about what we were going to find.
那一定是一种解脱。因为我知道你很焦虑，我也很焦虑，而且我面临的风险根本没有你那么大。
It really is a relief. I know her recollections are not as vivid as I had hoped. But you know, that's also good. It's also good that she's able to go ahead, and move from that to bond with her mom the way she did. I still think it would be very difficult for her to leave her mom.
这确实是一种解脱。我知道她的记忆不像我希望的那么生动。但是你知道，那也是好事。她能够继续前进，从那段经历中走出来，以她那样的方式与她母亲建立联系，这很好。我仍然认为让她离开她的妈妈对她来说会非常困难。
The next morning, Georgia, her mother, and her mother's friend Maury, picked us up at the hotel to visit their home. We wound our way along the serpentine roads of Jamaica's interior. It took half an hour to drive the eight miles, past groves of fruit trees, around hairpin turns. Through the center of Brown's Town, a bustling place where men were drinking beer and playing dominoes on the sidewalk. Margaret's house is rather remote, on the far outskirts of the town. We turned on to a rutted dirt road, and then on to another dirt road, which was a slushy brown from yesterday's rains.
第二天早上，乔治亚，她的母亲，和她母亲的朋友莫里，在酒店接我们去参观他们的家。我们沿着牙买加内陆蜿蜒的道路行驶。花了半小时开了八英里，经过果树林，绕过发夹弯。穿过布朗镇的中心，那是一个繁华的地方，男人们正在人行道上喝啤酒和玩多米诺骨牌。玛格丽特的家相当偏远，在城镇的最外围。我们转上一条坑坑洼洼的土路，然后转上另一条土路，那是昨天的雨留下的泥泞。
We finally pulled up alongside a narrow concrete structure, which had been built into a steep hill. Margaret's home had belonged to her uncle, who had recently died. In places, the concrete is chipped away. Most of the window panes are missing or broken. There's no plumbing. Margaret showed us around.
我们终于停在一个狭窄的混凝土结构旁边，它是建在一个陡峭的山坡上的。玛格丽特的家是她叔叔的，他刚去世。在某些地方，混凝土已经脱落。大多数窗玻璃不见了或破碎了。没有管道设施。玛格丽特带我们参观。
You see right now, in the next part there, the flooring needs to fix.
你看现在，在接下来的那个部分，地板需要修。
I see you put a patch there, huh?
我看到你打了个补丁，嗯？
Yeah.
是的。
Along one side of the house, Margaret had hung a shower curtain. On a table sat a yellow plastic tub.
沿着房子的侧面，玛格丽特挂了一块浴帘。桌上放着一个黄色的塑料桶。
So you fill up something, and then--
所以你把东西装满，然后——
Yeah.
是的。
OK, I see. So you've got to get this full and then you basically, you just kind of, OK. That works.
好的，明白了。所以你必须把它装满，然后你基本上，你只是那种，好吧。那行得通。
That's why I really want a better life for Georgia, you understand?
这就是为什么我真的希望乔治亚有一个更好的生活，你明白吗？
I see.
我明白。
Good.
很好。
We quickly realized that her mission for the day was to convince us how poor she was. In order for the adoption with Sheila to go through, one of the things that Margaret has to prove is that she's not able to adequately care for Georgia. She knew Hugo had an important job working with immigrant children. And so she hoped he'd have some influence.
我们很快意识到，她当天的任务是说服我们她有多贫困。为了让与希拉的收养顺利进行，玛格丽特需要证明的一件事是她无法充分照顾乔治亚。她知道雨果有一份重要的工作，致力于移民儿童。所以她希望他能有一定影响力。
With that in mind, Margaret showed us the front room where she and Georgia shared a bed. She pointed out two sheets of plywood, which covered a hole in the floor. She told us that her grown nephew, grown niece, and her niece's two year old son, stayed in two small rooms off to the side.
考虑到这一点，玛格丽特带我们看了前屋，她和乔治亚在那里共享一张床。她指出了两块覆盖地板洞的胶合板。她告诉我们，她已成年的侄子、成年侄女和她侄女的两岁儿子，住在旁边两个小房间里。
She took us into the kitchen, which is barely large enough for their two appliances, a gas stove and a rather small refrigerator. Which is empty, except for a pitcher of water and a brown bag of fruit. There are no sinks or cabinets. When I asked about her bathroom, she nodded to their pit toilet, which sits on a ridge a short walk from the house.
她带我们进了厨房，它小到几乎放不下他们的两件电器，一个煤气炉和一个相当小的冰箱。冰箱里是空的，除了一个装水的水壶和一袋棕色的水果。没有水槽或橱柜。当我问起她的卫生间时，她向他们的露天坑厕点头，它坐落在离房子不远的一个山脊上。
Margaret marched us from room to room with the indifference of a tired museum guide. It was clear that if she hadn't thought it might help Georgia's chances to go to the US, she wouldn't have had us there at all. For our part, it felt voyeuristic. It was, to be honest, terribly awkward. Hugo tried to put everyone at ease. At the back of the house, we walked over to a stone cistern, which collects their drinking water off the house's tin roof.
玛格丽特带着疲惫的博物馆导游的冷漠带着我们从一个房间走到另一个房间。很明显，如果她没有认为这可能有助于乔治亚去美国的机会，她根本不会让我们到那儿去。就我们而言，感觉就像是窥淫癖者。老实说，这真是尴尬透顶。雨果试图让每个人都感到自在。在房子后面，我们走到一个石制蓄水池旁，它收集屋顶上的雨水作为饮用水。
Swimming pool?
游泳池？
[LAUGHTER] Yeah.
（笑声）是的。
How full does it get? Does it get all the way to the top sometimes, or not?
它能装多满？有时候会装到顶吗，还是不？
Yeah. When the rain fall, all it fill up. And then it flow over. There's a lot of fish inside there now. So the fish will die once the fish are in there.
是的。当下雨时，它全装满了。然后它会流出来。现在里面有很多鱼。所以鱼进去之后就会死。
There are fish in your water here? How do they get them in?
你的水里有鱼吗？它们是怎么进去的？
My nephew bring them and put them in there.
我侄子抓来放在里面的。
Her nephew had dumped some river perch into the drinking water, which was murky, and which she usually boils before drinking. Hugo and Georgia wandered off to the side of the house.
她侄子往饮用水里倒了一些河鲈，水很浑浊，她通常喝之前会煮沸。雨果和乔治亚游荡到房子的侧面。
Georgia. You remember how I used to play, over there in Chicago, with [? Bi-wi ?] and Sagal? Sit down. Like this. The hands, patty cake.
乔治亚。你还记得我过去在芝加哥，和比威还有萨加尔是怎么玩的吗？坐下。像这样。手，拍手游戏。
Hugo sat down with Georgia to re-aquaint her with the game of patty cake.
雨果和乔治亚坐下来，重新帮她温习拍手游戏。
Then one like this. Back again. Then with this one, no, the other side. And then again, then down. Then up. Mm-mm-mm.
然后一个像这样。再回来。然后用这个，不，另一边。然后又一次，然后下来。然后上去。嗯-嗯-嗯。
As they played, Georgia very quietly brought up Chicago, as she did on the first night. She asked Hugo, if she were to come to America, and the same thing happened as last time, she gets stopped by immigration, would she end up with him?
当他们玩的时候，乔治亚很安静地提到了芝加哥，就像她在第一晚做的那样。她问雨果，如果她要去美国，而发生了和上次一样的事，她被移民局拦住了，她会和他在一起吗？
If I go back, and I don't have my visa, how would I [? reach ?] where you are?
如果我回去，我没有签证，我该怎么[找到]你在哪里？
Maybe, if they catch you, if they catch you. If they don't catch you, then you go with your, what's her name?
也许，如果他们抓住你，如果他们抓住你。如果他们没抓住你，那你就要和你，叫什么名字来着？
Sheila.
希拉。
Sheila. Where do you want to go, with Sheila, or with us?
希拉。你想去哪里，和希拉一起，还是和我们一起？
With you.
和你一起。
Hugo asked her why she wanted to return to Chicago. Because, she said, I want to see Sagal and [? Bi-wi. ?] Meanwhile, Margaret and I were talking on the front porch. We leaned on the railing overlooking the tropical bush and the dirt road. I asked Margaret why she was so intent on giving Georgia to Sheila.
雨果问她为什么要回芝加哥。她说，因为我喜欢那里。乔治亚想要见萨加尔和比威。与此同时，玛格丽特和我在前廊交谈。我们靠在俯瞰热带丛林和土路的栏杆上。我问玛格丽特为什么她那么执着于把乔治亚给希拉。
I really don't want to see her on the island. Because of violence, and all those things. You have a lot like those cool little boys, and don't go to school, and just, you know.
我真的不想在岛上看到她。因为暴力，还有所有那些事情。你有许多像那些酷酷的小男孩，不上学，只是，你知道。
She told me that the local boys, many of whom don't go to school, harass Georgia, often grabbing her by the hand. Margaret also said that she worked as a domestic. But only part-time, because she wanted to be at home each day when George arrived from school.
她告诉我当地的男孩，许多不上学的男孩，会骚扰乔治亚，经常抓住她的手。玛格丽特还说她做家政工。但只是兼职，因为她想每天在乔治亚放学回家时在家。
So you're worried that she's-- somebody might take advantage of her?
所以你担心她——有人可能会占她便宜？
Right.
没错。
Has that happened at all, have people tried to do that?
发生过这种情况吗，有人试过这样做吗？
Like one evening she come from school, and she's telling me that, mommy you know what the guy on the bus tell me? I said what. He's giving me three more here. I said what? Said he giving me three more here. Because like, she's eight now, innocent. So he giving her three more years.
就像有天晚上她从学校回来，她在告诉我，妈妈你知道公车上的那个人跟我说什么吗？我说什么。他给了我三个更多。我说什么？说他给了我三个更多。因为就像，她现在八岁了，无辜。所以他给了她三年更多。
Three more years?
三年更多？
Right.
没错。
Three more years. The guy on the bus meant that's when Georgia will be old enough to be a mother. Margaret, who's now 39, had her first child at 21. And eventually had six children by four different men. Georgia is her youngest. None of the men stuck around, including Georgia's father, who has disappeared from her life.
三年更多。公车上那个人意思是那是乔治亚到足够大可以当母亲的时候。玛格丽特，现在39岁，她在21岁时有了第一个孩子。最终和四个不同的男人生了六个孩子。乔治亚是她最小的。没有一个男人留下来，包括乔治亚的父亲，他已经从她的生活中消失了。
When Margaret's oldest turned 16, she informed Margaret that she was pregnant. When Margaret heard that, she cried.
当玛格丽特最大的孩子16岁时，她告诉玛格丽特她怀孕了。当玛格丽特听到那个时，她哭了。
So, I just don't want to see that happen to Georgia, I just want her to grow up. And have things, have what she can have, innocence. Like go to school and take her education. Pass her subject and get a nice job before she go on to wherever she go, have kids. Cannot walk in my footstep.
所以，我只是不想看到那种事发生在乔治亚身上，我只是想让她长大。并且拥有一些东西，拥有她能拥有的，纯真。比如去上学接受教育。通过她的科目，找一份好工作，然后无论去哪儿，再生孩子。不能走我的老路。
She can't walk in my footsteps, Margaret says. Not I hope she doesn't, she can't. Margaret was adamant about that.
她不能走我的老路，玛格丽特说。不是我希望她不，她是不能。玛格丽特对此很坚持。
Do you ever think, how am I going to be here without my daughter?
你有没有想过，没有我女儿我该怎么待在这里？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. I always survived. I just want the best for her.
[听不清]。我总是幸存下来。我只是想给她最好的。
But it's got to be hard for you. I can tell how close you are with Georgia.
但这一定很难。我可以看出你和乔治亚有多亲近。
Yeah but, the reason why is because I don't have anybody to help me. So I want to do something for myself, because I don't want to lean on anyone for saying, give me this and give me that, now give me this. I want to have something for myself, actually something for myself too. I'm getting old. I'm 39 years old. I want to have something for myself, you know friend?
是的，但原因是，因为我没有任何人可以帮助我。所以我想要为自己做点什么，因为我不想依赖任何人说，给我这个那个，现在又给我这个。我想为自己拥有一些东西，其实也为我自己。我变老了。我39岁了。我想为自己拥有一些东西，你知道朋友？
But it's got to be so hard as a mother to let go.
但这作为一个母亲要放手一定非常难。
Margaret didn't answer. She swatted at the mosquitoes. She stared at the bush on the other side of the road. I wondered if, given her reality, she had by necessity stopped asking herself these questions. All I could think to say to break the long silence was--
玛格丽特没有回答。她拍打着蚊子。她盯着路对面的灌木丛。我想知道，考虑到她的现实，她是否出于必要停止问自己这些问题。我唯一能想到打破长久沉默的话是——
It's quite humid, huh?
这里相当潮湿，嗯？
As we spent time in Jamaica, it became clear that Georgia's situation was not at all extraordinary. Virtually everyone we met had a similar story to tell. During the drive from Kingston to Runaway Bay, we had told our driver, [? Ollie Forester, ?] about Georgia. And he said that just a few days earlier, a complete stranger had left a five year old boy carrying a backpack full of clothes at the gate to his father's house.
当我们待在牙买加时，很明显乔治亚的情况一点都不特别。我们遇到的几乎每个人都有类似的故事要讲。在从金斯敦到鲁纳韦湾的路上，我们告诉了我们的司机，奥利·福雷斯特，关于乔治亚的事。他说就在几天前，一个完全陌生的人把一个五岁大的小男孩带着装满衣服的背包留在了他父亲家的大门口。
They just left one at the gate. They just left him at the gate, and just leave him like that. His mother just come, and leave him like that.
他们只是把一个留在了大门口。他们只是把他留在大门口，就这样留着他。他妈妈只是来，就这样留着他。
So your father's taking care of a child now?
所以你父亲现在在照顾一个孩子？
Yes, right now. Yeah. And it's not the first time.
是的，就在现在。是的。而且这也不是第一次。
[? Ollie's ?] father, a farmer in his 70s, plans to raise this child. Maybe even legally adopt him, if he can find the mother. Then when we visited the Sunflower Hotel, where Margaret and Sheila first met, we encounter the hotel's owner, Vana Taylor. She told us this story of how she came to take in a child seven years ago. The child is now eleven. Vana was at the beach early one morning and saw a mother with her daughter. It was a school day.
奥利的父亲，一个70多岁的农民，计划抚养这个孩子。如果他能找到那个母亲的话，甚至可能合法收养他。后来当我们访问玛格丽特和希拉第一次见面的向日葵酒店时，我们遇到了酒店的老板，瓦娜·泰勒。她告诉了我们七年前她如何收留一个孩子的故事。那个孩子现在11岁。瓦娜有一天清晨在沙滩上看到一个母亲和她的女儿。那天是上学日。
And I said, why is the child not at school? Because I'm always worried about that. And then the mother said, I have no clothes, I have no food, I have nothing to send the child to school. So I said to her, you know, why don't you give me the child, or something like that. And then she said, fine, you know. She said to the child, do you want to go live with Ms. Taylor, and the child said, yes. That was it.
我说，为什么这个孩子不去上学？因为我总是担心这个。然后那个母亲说，我没有衣服，没有食物，我什么都没有送孩子去上学。所以我对她说，你知道，你为什么不把孩子给我，诸如此类。然后她说，好吧，你知道。她对那个孩子说，你想去和泰勒小姐住吗，那个孩子说，是的。就这样。
That matter of fact.
那么理所当然。
That matter of fact. And by the time I got home, she was here. It's very easy, it's much easier than having one, isn't it? [LAUGHTER]
那么理所当然。等我回家时，她已经在这里了。这很容易，比生一个容易多了，不是吗？（笑声）
There's a saying in Jamaica that once the children [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE} kitten. Meaning that just like a cat, people give away their children.
牙买加有句谚语，一旦孩子们[听不清]小猫。意思是就像猫一样，人们把他们的孩子送人。
This is Claudette Pious who works with children in Spanish Town, near Kingston. She says it's actually rare for Jamaican children to be sent to America. Usually it's the parents who go, leaving behind their children with family, friends, or sometimes on their own. It's become so common that there's a name for the kids left behind, barrel children. Because they receive barrels of goods from their parents, mostly name-brand shoes and clothes.
这是克劳黛特·派厄斯，她在金斯敦附近的西班牙镇与孩子们一起工作。她说牙买加孩子被送往美国其实很罕见。通常是父母自己去，把孩子留在亲戚、朋友，有时甚至是他们自己身边。这变得如此普遍，以至于留下的孩子有一个名字，桶装孩子。因为他们从父母那里收到一桶桶的商品，主要是名牌鞋和衣服。
Claudette herself was abandoned. Her mother emigrated to Canada in search of work, and left Claudette behind with an aunt. Claudette told me she never forgave her mother.
克劳黛特自己就被遗弃了。她的母亲移民到加拿大寻找工作，留下了克劳黛特和一位阿姨在一起。克劳黛特告诉我她从来没有原谅过她的母亲。
I got many letters. I still have some. And I can remember her sending me a tape recorder. And saying, I should talk on the tape recorder and send the tapes to her. I'd just sit by myself, and talk to this tape recorder. Sometimes I'd quarrel with her. Sometimes I'd tell her all the things happening. Sometimes it was almost like a diary. If it was a good day, I would tell her. Some bad days, I would tell her. But interestingly, I didn't send the tapes.
我收到过很多信。我现在还有一些。我记得她寄给我一个录音机。说，我应该在录音机上说话并将磁带寄给她。我只是一个人坐着，对着这个录音机说话。有时我会和她争吵。有时我会告诉她发生的所有事情。有时它几乎就像日记。如果是美好的一天，我会告诉她。一些糟糕的日子，我也会告诉她。但有趣的是，我没有寄出这些磁带。
In her work with children today, Claudette won't take any in. She won't build a shelter. She feels it's too important that they stay with their own families. Her own mother eventually returned to Jamaica when Claudette was an adult.
在她今天与孩子的工作中，克劳黛特不会收留任何一个。她不会建避难所。她认为让他们和自己的家庭待在一起太重要了。她自己的母亲最终在她成年时回到了牙买加。
I remember saying to her, that whatever I become in life have nothing to do with you.
我记得我对她说，我在生活中成为什么样的人与你无关。
That's what you said to your mother?
那是你对你母亲说的？
And she was very upset. And she said, I was very ungrateful because she supported me. She send the money. And I said, it's not about the money. It's about that connection, not being there for me when I wanted to cry, when I wanted to laugh, when I wanted to-- just to hold you, and I wanted you to be close.
她非常难过。她说，我非常不知好歹，因为她支持了我。她寄了钱。我说，这无关钱。这关于那种联系，当我想要哭的时候你不在我身边，当我想要笑的时候，当我想要——只是抱着你，我想要你靠近我。
Hugo believes what Claudette does, that if at all possible kids should stay with their parents. And like Claudette, he had had his own experience. Growing up in Peru, his family at one point fell on hard times. His mother had the chance to give him up. An uncle offered to raise him. But she held on to Hugo. It was more important to her, poor or not, that her son be with his mom.
雨果相信克劳黛特所做的，如果可能的话，孩子们应该和他们的父母待在一起。像克劳黛特一样，他有自己的经历。在秘鲁长大，他的家人有一次遭遇了困境。他的母亲有机会放弃他。一位叔叔提议抚养他。但她坚持留下了雨果。对她来说，无论贫穷与否，儿子和妈妈在一起更重要。
But in the nine years Hugo has been at the children's center, he's begun to understand why parents might let go of their children. He learned it first through the children from India, whose parents had been conned by smugglers into thinking they were sending their children to America to attend great schools and to live with well to-do families. When in fact, the smugglers planned to put them to work at menial jobs. Hugo would occasionally talk by phone with these parents. And the first thing they'd ask about were the schools their children presumably attended.
但在雨果在儿童中心工作的九年里，他开始理解父母为什么要放手他们的孩子。他首先通过来自印度的孩子了解了这一点，他们的父母被走私者骗了，以为把孩子送到美国去上好学校和富裕家庭生活。事实上，走私者计划让他们去做低微的工作。雨果偶尔会和这些父母通电话。他们问的第一件事就是孩子们想必在上的学校。
I used to be fairly judgemental as far as that went. There's a lot of people that do not understand. But I understand today why they separate from their children. And I don't think they love them any less than we love our children. I just think that they're so desperate that they don't have any other options. And I understand that piece a lot better today.
我过去对此相当喜欢评判。有很多人不理解。但我今天理解为什么他们与孩子分离。我不认为他们爱他们比我们爱我们的孩子少。我只是认为他们是如此绝望，以至于他们没有其他选择。今天我能更好地理解那一部分。
The interesting thing that perplexes me, I mean I think I can understand the first time around. Georgia's really young, she's three years old, and Margaret's living a really difficult life. A woman comes along who she clearly on some level admires, maybe doesn't know well, and offers to take Georgia. And Margaret goes along with it. And then everything goes awry, and she gets her kid back. And I would think that would be the most glorious moment in some ways. You know, her--
令我困惑的有趣的事情是，我的意思是我想我能理解第一次。乔治亚非常小，只有三岁，玛格丽特过着非常困难的生活。一个女人出现了，她显然在某种程度上钦佩她，可能不了解，并提议带走乔治亚。玛格丽特就那样做了。然后一切都出错了，她又把孩子接回来了。我以为那在某些方面会是最辉煌的时刻。你知道，她的——
And she doesn't come across that way.
她看起来不是那样的。
Yeah, and that she doesn't want-- she's still willing. Here we are four years later, and she's still willing and ready to give Georgia up.
是的，她并不想——她依然愿意。四年后我们在这里，她依然愿意并准备好把乔治亚送走。
I think of what goes through Georgia's head right now. And I'm sure she has questions as well. That she's not able to express to her mom, or maybe to anyone. Not yet anyway. Later on, I'm sure that she'll want some answers.
我想此时此刻乔治亚脑子里在想什么。我相信她也有问题。她无法向她的妈妈，或者可能向任何人表达这些。还没到那时候。我相信以后她会想要一些答案。
What kind of questions?
什么样的问题？
You know, why am I being sent here again? I'm here with my mom. And at this age, it's going to be a fairly difficult separation, legal or not. It's going to be a difficult situation. But I don't know that Georgia will ever forget at this age. Because Georgia is now in what I consider to be a stable environment. And this is where she should remain.
你知道，为什么我又被送走了？我和我妈妈在一起。在这个年龄，这将是一个相当困难的分离，无论合法与否。那将是一个困难的情况。但我不知道乔治亚在这个年龄是否会忘记。因为乔治亚现在处于我认为稳定的环境中。这是她应该待的地方。
[SINGING] Don't worry about a thing. 'Cause every little thing is going to be all right. Tell you don't worry about a thing.
（唱歌）不要担心任何事。因为每一件小事都会没事的。告诉你不要担心任何事。
That night at the hotel bar, Georgia sang along to the piano player.
那天晚上在酒店酒吧，乔治亚跟着钢琴演奏者唱歌。
[SINGING] Rising sun in the morning, smile with the rising sun. Three little birds--
（唱歌）晨光升起，带着初升的太阳微笑。三只小鸟——
Margaret looked on, beaming. It was the one time she seemed completely unburdened. And it was the same with Georgia, as well. Ironically, one of the reason she's doing so well, is Sheila. Who sends $50 to $100 every couple of weeks. She's also paying for Georgia's private school education.
玛格丽特看着，眉开眼笑。这是她看起来完全无负担的一次。乔治亚也是如此。具有讽刺意味的是，她表现良好的原因之一是希拉。她每隔几周寄来50到100美元。她还在支付乔治亚私立学校的教育费用。
[SINGING] Singing sweet songs of melodies pure and true. This is our message to you.
（唱歌）唱着纯真而真实的旋律的甜美歌曲。这是我们给你的信息。
We left the next day after stopping by to bring Georgia presents and a cake to celebrate her eighth birthday. As she waits for adults in two countries to figure out her fate, I suppose a hopeful thing is that she's been in the same place before, and came out of it OK. Or so it seemed. What has to be toughest on Georgia though, are all the unknowns. Hugo once told me that the longer he works with children like Georgia, it becomes more complicated, not less. So many of these children, they don't seem to fully belong anywhere.
我们第二天离开，在顺道去给乔治亚送礼物和蛋糕庆祝她八岁生日之后。当她等待两个国家的成年人弄清楚她的命运时，我想希望的是，她以前去过同样的地方，并且出来得很好。至少看起来是这样。乔治亚必须面对最艰难的事情是所有的未知数。雨果曾经告诉我，他与像乔治亚这样的孩子工作的时间越长，事情就越复杂，而不是越简单。这么多孩子，他们似乎哪里都不完全属于。
Alex Kotlowitz. His most recent book is Never a City So Real. Four years ago when Georgia came to the United States, about 5,000 minors were stopped at US borders and airports. This year, 6,300 are expected. The number of residential centers for them, like the one Hugo runs, has jumped from eight to twenty, in just four years.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨。他最近的书是《从没这么真实的城市》。四年前当乔治亚来到美国时，约有5000名未成年人在美国边境和机场被拦下。今年，预计达到6300人。他们的居住中心数量，像雨果运营的那个，在短短四年内从八个增加到二十个。
Our program's produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachman and Will [? Reichel ?]. It is Will's last show. He's performed bravely and capably in the face of great adversity, and we are sorry to see him go.
我们节目的制作人是黛安·库克和我自己，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格和莉萨·波拉克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特管理我们的网站。制作帮助来自托德·巴赫曼和威尔[听不清]。这是威尔的最后一场节目。他在巨大的逆境面前表现得勇敢而能干，我们很遗憾看到他离开。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for free. Or you know you can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife. Where they have public radio programs, best selling books, even the New York Times, all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目。或者你知道你可以下载我们节目的音频在 audible.com/thisamericanlife。那里有公共广播节目，畅销书，甚至纽约时报，都在 audible.com。 《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. In the crowded gym locker room, I can report to you, he just repeats this mantra over and over--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚。在拥挤的健身房更衣室里，我可以向你们报告，他只是反复念诵这个咒语——
"Can't throw in the towel. Can't throw in the towel."
“不能轻易放弃。不能轻易放弃。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。